how do share owners keep
abreast of their own companies
what information goes into a firm's annual
report who put out this financial statement
meet one of the 12 and a half million owners
of american industry who risk their savings
in hope of financial reward from the industrial
enterprise that has made america prosperous how do
investors like this know what their companies are
doing they're kept informed by such things as the
annual report containing a balance sheet income
statement and generally a great deal more take for
example this report by a company that pioneered
in the manufacture of safety razors and blades
the costly automatic machines which today mass
produced blades by the billions every year
are dramatic evidence of what the annual
report means when it tells of assets
behind them as earlier reports would show
stands a record of growth almost as rapid
as the tempo of the machines themselves
these assets descended from a man with
an idea for a different way to shave they
were made possible by his efforts and by
the capital the public was willing to risk
on his venture continuously reinvesting part
of the earnings to create new assets new
wealth for workers and share owners alike
the pages of the annual report also show how
companies often diversify as they grow this one
added not only new shaving products but pens as
well acquiring this leading manufacturer of ball
point writing instruments by paying 15 million
dollars at the time management decided to add
this venture to earlier successes the reasons
were spelled out carefully for the share owners
who might have instigated some changes of
their own had there been major disagreement
but the acquisition was well made and
well-timed as succeeding reports recorded much
of the investment being recovered through added
profits from the pens in only a few short years
as the additions of new products and new divisions
are reported the owners find their opportunities
further multiplied their investment has grown
large enough to take them into the manufacture
distribution and sale of feminine beauty
preparations this phase started with purchase
of a company making home permanent wave kits and
it led very quickly to further diversification
and the addition of new employees as
management complemented the various
waving products with shampoos spray nets and
a complete line of hair styling accessories
thus payment for the acquisition was just the
beginning now this firm like others plows back
newly gained profits to meet new competition to
ensure continued growth by the time these scenes
were filmed the parent company was little more
than 50 years old in this short lifetime it had
quickly outgrown the tiny machine shop where it
was born from larger quarters it took its products
and new facilities to produce them overseas and
around the world before adding the newer items
like these items that have helped produce net
annual sales of more than 200 million dollars
for most of the thousands of owners whose
capital made this achievement possible it
would be impractical to visit personally even as
much of their property as our cameramen have seen
so widespread and vast is it today but in the
pages of their annual reports they receive a full
accounting keeping up to date not only on today's
events but on the future too as it develops in
their company's modern research laboratories here
scores of scientific and technical experts are
employed to find ways to improve all products
and production methods and to find brand new
products as well again plow back up profits
is required to back the researchers new ideas
and to pay for the plants and equipment that will
produce them for the market will every project pay
off not by a long shot progress isn't easy it's a
risky business in fact but without it prosperity
would soon wither without continuing investment
in research the march of progress would come to a
halt
this project involves new inks for ball point pins
and here in a room where temperature and
humidity are carefully and constantly controlled
we see one of many tests on fibers and fabrics
what do stockholders think when the reports
show how costly such research work can be
by and large they approve wholeheartedly
with many investors actually preferring
to own shares in companies that are aggressively
research-minded feeling confident that companies
spending a good part of their earnings on research
will ultimately return a profit on the investment
in research the tools in use sometimes seem as
advanced as the improvements they help achieve
here radioactivity measures the detergent
remaining in a sample of hair after washing
another project that costs money today but
tomorrow may turn up on the profit side of
the annual report a document that makes public
regularly the workings of industry the public owns
now let's see how the report itself is
assembled beginning with a conference that
in all probability will bring together
top executives of the company involved
and artists writers and production
men who are expert at the job
of presenting a complex array of facts in
simple attractive and easy to understand form
everyone works under the pressure of a firm
deadline when annual reports are being assembled
for the finished printing job must be in
the hands of the share owners within three
months of the close of the fiscal year and
at least 15 days before the annual meeting
among the earliest steps is the selection of
photographs now used in a majority of reports
they will probably be pictures of the firm's
plants and offices an oil company will want to
include shots of its refineries the pictures
make the finished report more attractive and
they also sum up graphically a story that
otherwise could not be so effectively told
a firm that makes parts for nuclear submarines
may use a photograph to emphasize that point
so the work proceeds with layout artists getting
a start even before the final figures are in
and through it all the figures themselves are
taking shape often with the help of electronic
computers which make fast work of the inventories
cash on hand sales earnings per share and the like
the figures are the heart of the annual report
as rapidly as they're compiled and checked
they're passed along to the production workers
who already know exactly where they should go
on exactly what page the system is much the same
as that used in the production of a magazine with
dummies or mock-ups of the various pages
helping the staff keep track of the
progress
a final conference is called
to make last-minute changes
to check on accuracy and to approve
the booklet or brochure for printing
now the type is locked in place
or the offset master's completed
and the presses take over the work the
number of copies they turn out depending
basically on the number of people who share
ownership of a particular company for some
this means a few thousand for others
it may mean a million copies and more
there must be at least one copy for
every owner whether his interest is
as little as one share or as
large as hundreds of thousands
for annual reports the circulation usually is
larger than the list of stockholders including
many others employees customers dealers
the financial community civic leaders and
newsmen corporations distribute an average of
49 000 reports beyond the number required for
share owners such wide distribution of so much
information is unique in america only in this
country is full disclosure of facts about publicly
owned corporations a matter of routine policy
one of the addresses that frequently turns up
on the mailing list is that of the committee
the judge's annual reports in a contest conducted
by financial world magazine its prizes have been
called the oscars of industry at the head of
the table financial public relations council
weston smith originated the idea which involves
initially a large-scale screening that brings
the number of entries down to manageable size
for the experts who make the final decisions
the contest is credited with inspiring growing
awareness of the importance of annual reports
in which the judges looked especially for
comprehensive coverage of essential figures
for easy readability and for eye appeal
to mention just a few of the criteria
in years gone by annual reports were much
smaller much less informative than they are
today often a small card was all there was to
a report then they evolved into larger folders
and this form was the logical end result of
industry's efforts to present full information
in an attractive manner easily understood
sometimes unusual methods are employed
a record company for example has put its
president's message on a disc a manufacturer
of gains in educational materials has used
a three-dimensional graph that pops up when the
report is opened to attract attention to key facts
and another report gains share owner interest
by inviting the reader to pull out various tabs
another unusual method of presentation
involves the use of supplements in sunday
newspapers the readership for these
supplements is rated in the millions
in the continuing campaign to extend knowledge
about their operations to an ever wider
audience companies frequently take smaller
advertisements in newspapers and magazines
the gist of their annual reports this widespread
dissemination of the facts about american industry
may help explain why today one out of every eight
americans own stock in one or more corporations
here a few thousand of those individuals
some of the five hundred thousand who
own stock in one firm gather for their
annual meeting although only a fraction
of the company's owners attend the largest
auditorium in town is filled to overflowing
chief purpose of the gathering is to let the
share owners hear directly from management a
more detailed account of the year's activities
as described in the annual report that was sent
out at least two weeks prior to this meeting
after management has talked the stockholders
are heard from as they let management know
what they think of the way things are going
for these men and women all just average citizens
are the real owners of american industry the
capitalists constantly under attack in some areas
of the world but vocal expression is only one
way the share owner makes his opinion known for
secret ballots on all issues have been sent out
to each one and now as the meeting
proceeds those ballots are counted
unlike the phony product peddled from behind the
iron curtain this is a real people's capitalism